how do we represent rational numbers on
a number line a number line looks
something like this the positive
integers are represented towards the
right of zero and the negative integers
are represented to the left of zero the
numbers increase when we move towards
the right and decrease when we move
towards the left it's easy to plot
integers but how do we plot numbers like
three by four before we understand how
to plot this we need to understand a
very crucial point every integer except
zero has a corresponding integer the
integer one has minus one as its
corresponding integer the integer two
has minus two as its corresponding
integer
similarly every negative integer will
have a corresponding positive integer
this tells us that if we somehow managed
to plot three by four we can mark a
point at the same distance on the left
hand side of zero which is minus 3 by 4
now we can move on to the representation
of rational numbers on a number line to
simplify things we can classify the
examples into two types once in which
the numerator is less than the
denominator and the other in which the
numerator is greater than the
denominator note that we see only the
numerical value to compare the numerator
and the denominator for example if we
are plotting minus 9 by 5 we compare 9
and 5 and not minus 9 and 5 so minus 9
by 5 will come in the numerator greater
than denominator category we will look
at two examples of the first category in
the next video
you